hi everyone welcome to my video series
of bio techniques explain me in 10
minutes when I explain a biological
technique in less than 10 minutes or so
if you haven't yet subscribed to my
channel yet hit that subscribe button
why are you waiting for now today's
installment we're going to talk about
fluorescence recovery after
photobleaching experiment it's a good
biological technique which has versatile
use so fluorescence recovery after
photobleaching or in short fab is
majorly used to study molecular dynamics
so let's quickly review the application
of frappé in biological research so Fred
could be used to study membrane fluidity
or studying the mobility of a membrane
protein it can be also study used to
study cytoskeletal dynamics and dynamics
of basically transport quantitative
information about all these dynamic
processes can be obtained using frapp so
the trap is very important for cell
biologists so we're going to talk about
how frapp works and then we are going to
review some trap based experiments and
how to interpret the data but before
that guys if we haven't yet subscribe
please subscribe and hit that Bell like
they like and and please share my videos
in social media by the way I'm also
present in an academy so if you want to
join my course use epic 10 as a code
that would give you 10% discount so
let's start let's take an example of
membrane fluidity so we know that
membrane are fluid and all these
phospholipids can either diffuse
laterally or it could have a rotational
motion or it could have movement so
let's try to understand whether how we
can detect or experimentally determine
that these phospholipids are actually
performing lateral movements in order to
do so you need to take a cell in culture
format and then we are going to label
the lipids with fluorescently marks
lipids after incorporating the lipids
inside the membrane which would take
some time then all the membrane is
fluorescently labeled right this
tuition using a confocal microscope or a
strong fluorescent microscope we are
going to bleach a portion of the
membrane so you can see the top view and
now we introduce our laser and this is a
very high intensity laser which would
bleach a portion of the membrane and all
the fury scenes in that area would be
lost so the area would now look like
this a bleached region you have to
understand that if these phospholipids
are not mobile they are static then this
bleached region would be never recovered
right but in other words if they are
dynamic then this fluorescent bleached
region would be recovered over time so
what scientists perform is like they
track the fluorescent level over time
after please and that is known as a
recovery phase let's say the membrane
phospholipids are mobile and performing
lateral movements so after waiting for
some time they would be recovering or
gradual recovery of fluorescence because
nearby phospholipids are performing
lateral diffusions and coming to this
bleached region that's why the bleach
the bleached region is now gaining again
fluorescence right now let's try to look
at the data and try to interpret it so
the data comes out from the microscope
as an intensity versus time data so
there is a certain amount of intensity
level level because the membrane was
labeled by fluorescently labeled
phospholipids as a result is a baseline
intensity but whenever we expose this
membrane with the high intensity laser
right now there would be a sharp drop in
the fluorescent level right because this
is the bleaching phase like what the
photo bleaching is happening so this
phase is the photo bleaching now we have
to wait and if these membrane
phospholipids are dynamic then they
would be gradual recovering and this is
how it is depicted there is a gradual
recovery and as a recovery the fusions
is regained or come
back right so let's see how
quantitatively we can understand this
data actually these diffusion of the the
phospholipids would proceed in a ordered
fashion and assuming the beam which is
bleaching is actually Gaussian having a
quotient profile then we can calculate
the diffusion coefficient the diffusion
coefficient D would be R square by 40 T
where T D is the time for diffusion and
R square is the radius of this beam
which was used for bleaching purpose
with that it would give a quantitative
measure about the diffusion coefficient
it would also give us an estimate of
time that how much time it would require
for recovering right so let's try to
understand this process in bit more
details so let's take another example
how to track the dynamic nature of a
membrane protein so let's say this red
membrane protein over here is actually
dynamic in nature so it actually moves
right in the membrane so we can see from
the side and the top view that this
particular red protein is quite mobile
inside the plasma membrane it is not
necessary that all membrane wrong
protein need to be mobile but some of
the membrane bound put the protein can
be mobile and in order to track their
mobility we can use that or we can ask
the question that this particular
protein is mobile or not in order to do
so we need to tag the protein
fluorescently we need to make a
recombinant protein that will Express
GFP or somehow they will the protein bit
of fluorescent tag now the same protein
can move right so if we bleach a certain
region on the membrane and if the same
protein can move here and there then
what would happen then there would be a
initial dip in the fluorescence due to
photobleaching but overall there would
be a recovery profile over time right
and that would tell us about the
mobility of this particular protein
right so here after giving the laser
some amount of proteins here are
bleached
can see the proteins are faded out right
now the proteins which are in the nearby
location would eventually migrate and
take the position of those proteins as a
result overall fluorescence would be
regained so looking at the fluorescence
recovery profile or calculating the
diffusion coefficient we can understand
how dynamic a biological process is or
we can understand the quantitative
aspect of dynamics of a protein or a
membrane phospholipid let's take another
example now we're going to ask that how
vesicular transport can be studied using
frapp so we know inside our cells there
are microtubules
which are like highways and there are
trucks or there are vehicles like kind
of things diamines these are molecular
motors right and they take the cargo and
allow the cargo to be transported from
one location to another location
especially for long cells cells which
are having long processes like the
neurons this kind of transport is very
important for their normal normal
physiology so inside the neuron there
would be long long tracks of
microtubules and on top of microtubules
these molecular motors would move but
how do you prove these molecular motors
are dynamic in nature one thing out of
them anything what we can do is to label
these kind of molecular motors with
fluorescent markers and after that the
whole axon of the neuron would kind of
look like fluorescent because if the
movement is happening all of the amazon
would be labeled properly right now we
still don't know their dynamic or static
it could be also these cargos are
separately distributed all over their
source and that's why they are labeling
the whole eggs on green but now what we
are going to do we are going to use a
high intensity laser to bleach amory
portion of that axon now when the laser
is removed we would wait for the
recovery profile if recovery happens
then the process is dynamic if the
recovery doesn't happen then the process
is static let's see what happens so in
that region region if we track over time
then what we would see that many motors
from nearby region
try to come in the breached region and
that would recover the fluorescence
profile so as a result our fluorescent
profile would look like this
so initially there was a baseline
density which dropped dramatically due
to photo bleaching and then what happens
there is a recovery right and this is
only possible because the process is
dynamic so in this video we learn how to
study membrane fluidity using using FRAP
we also studied how to use trap
technique to study membrane protein
dynamics or how to study intracellular
transport we also learn how to interpret
the frapp data in a simple manner right
so if you liked this video give a thumbs
up and don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you guys